hello world and hello people of native
Ling I am Jessica from Kampf Tom and I'm
so excited to be a guest here talking
about the intersection between language
and code I am also really excited to be
here at YouTube space New York
there are amazing cameras this super
talented crew you even get to see me
dance can laugh at it comment alright
let's get down to business and find out
if computer languages even count as
languages I think they're do spoiler
alert
I'm so jealous right now
I just found out that 10th graders like
Sally are gonna start getting foreign
language credit for learning to program
games on their iPhones no slogging
through years of conjugating Sarah and a
star like I had to do but you know
Sally's mom Susa she's a bit if hear
about this because she says that
programming languages with all the curly
braces and weird semicolons and strange
Mathew symbols are nothing like a
foreign language is she right is
mouthing looking code like this really a
language language welcome to compchomp
the only show on the internets where we
crack jokes in binary 0 1 1 0 1 1 0 0 1
haha
don't get me wrong I actually really
enjoyed my time in high school Spanish
maybe don't ask me to order a meal when
we're out because you are most likely
going to get the cabeza de Chivo sorry
now I'm a programmer and I get to look
back and wonder when I was learning
Spanish was I really doing anything
different than when I was learning to
code I mean in my code I use words I use
syntax to put those words together and I
even use related languages and dialects
oh that's right in programming there are
language dialects it all sounds so
language e but does it look language e
fax alert will will woo you know it's
going to be good facts because these are
my good fax glasses if you wanted to how
do you think you could tell whether
learning to program was like learning a
foreign language you could round up a
bunch of programmers and just shove them
into an MRI and scan their brains while
they're reading
and that is exactly what Yanet zigmund
and team did
kudos guys actually no I'm a programmer
and I really hate enclosed spaces don't
put me in there so let's say that you're
a coder and you're holed up in an MRI
machine and they show you this what does
it mean well let's read it together I'm
a program stick label var1 on the number
23 and another label var2 on the number
42 now pull out a label temp but don't
put it anywhere just yet now take temp
and stick it where var1 is then peel off
var1 and stick it over there with var2
and you can now take var 2 and put it
back where tempus after this whole run
around which number did our label var1
end up on that's right we switched them
all right this this is kind of fun I
like reading code let's do another one
I'm a program too so this is Otto who
wears the nametag word give me a switch
to flip when I get the right answer and
give that switch the nametags result
start one counter counting up from zero
and another one counting down from the
end of the word as a first counter
counts up and the second counter counts
down you go until you reach the middle
of the word and at each count compare
the two letters and if they are the same
keep going but if they're different flip
the results switch to false and stop
doing everything you're done just tell
us whether result is true or false did
you figure out what this did yet come on
I know one of you language guys has it
figured out we just checked if Otto is a
palindrome and for those of you that
aren't sure Otto is so what type of
brain patterns do you think lit up when
coders were reading code like this
probably just the ones that deal with
math right all right totally wrong it's
the ones that deal with language and
memory basically being a fluent coder
looks a whole lot like being a native
speaker one-two punch
it's my uppercut or my job go out right
now and demand foreign language credits
for your programming smarts if your goal
is to teach someone to think in a new
language you pretty much can't go wrong
with
programming unless you're teaching basic
you need to stop teaching the kids basic
it is not a good idea
details to come later tragic traumatic
details but you know if your goal is to
have a whole cultural experience to read
Don Quixote and accidentally ordered a
visit achieve oh it's not really
something you can do in C alright I hope
you'll spend a few more videos with this
programmer talking language I'm Jessica
from compchomp subscribe for more about
how code is part of your everyday life
and hang around here on native language
series of videos together about the
awesome overlap between code and
language shop